one aspect of the technosphere that is
particularly challenging but also offers
some great possibilities
and by the technosphere what i mean is
this inner penetration of the the
internet and its technology into all
sorts of aspects of our life in ways
that that are ongoing and
are quite
radically new
uh especially for those of us in
generations that that grew up before the
internet
so anyway one of the the aspects that's
that's particularly interesting
is our access to news and i think that
we get
in many respects at least at this time
deeper and broader access to news
through the internet than we do through
other news outlets like the television
or radio
or or print journalism
there there are certain
certain ways in which i would say
especially with print journalism um you
you know you don't want to dismiss it
all together
but
for the most part
what's good in print journalism is
available online now
and so we're posed with this this issue
of how to be
good consumers
how to become well informed about what's
going on in the world and even in our
own little portions of the world
so
i got this great question
on
one of one of the comments on my uh
channel update for for the year the the
january channel update and it's from
uh
tf
141 ghost
and
it runs like this this is a little off
subject but i i would still enjoy your
opinion you mentioned the atlantic and
the guardian and i'm curious as to where
you get your news from
as a young adult as a young individual a
voting age within the us i feel like i
have a duty to be knowledgeable and
perhaps even active in regards to
politics and current events in general
so my question to you is where can i
find the least biased news sources to
form an educated opinion on current
events it's a great question
and i not only like the question i also
like this sort of set of assumptions
that in order to to really
be the kind of person that you ought to
be it means being well informed being
educated and that being educated doesn't
just mean having learned things but
being ready to take in new information
and do something with it and and not
just take in information as information
but to be able to put it into
perspectives to be able to to fit it
together and in this this case it's it's
a question about
uh where do you get the most
reliable or bias-free information from
now there's a lot of things that i want
to say about this that that fit in with
the theme of this particular video
i also want to from the very beginning
sort of peel off some other issues that
i think would be great to talk about in
other videos
one of those is i i'm not going to talk
here about how to do research
or you know what the technosphere
affords us in terms of research
and i'm not going to talk about how you
do that for
older topics i'm going to talk in this
mostly about current events
we're talking about news sources here so
that includes opinion sources as well
but we're not going to talk about things
like wikipedia or or those sorts of
things the other thing that i'm not
going to go into although it's a
fascinating topic
particularly from the vantage point that
i have as a gen xer
is
what the access to news has done
to the way that we even look at news and
the way that we
participate in it and consume it and
share it and talk about it and think
about it
there's some really important
technological and generational changes
that have taken place and that's that's
a great topic again for another video
so to come back to this video what am i
going to talk about i'm going to talk
about this this question of bias
and about news sources and about some
strategies
that uh are are available
for
um
for a person who wants to be well
informed and wants to be careful about
what they're
what they're assenting to what they're
saying yeah maybe it could be the case
and what they're saying uh that's that's
definitely uh off there
so
from the beginning i want to say there's
going to be some sources where you can
tell pretty quickly
that they're biased
and that their bias is going to really
interfere with the kind of news that
you're getting
i would say
that sources that are
that are
very far on one ideological spectrum or
another
which
don't make any sort of effort to
understand their opposed ideological
views and there are many sources like
that are going to be very bad news
sources
bias is often quite a bit more subtle
particularly when we get to the middle
parts of of the spectrum it's it's
interesting
that in my experience
these days
conservatives um many conservatives
think that they're not biased at all in
their their views in how they filter
information and what they pay attention
to
but i would say that
less conservatives
fail to acknowledge their bias than than
liberals
i i see a lot of liberals who just
assume that that progressivism or a
liberal point of view or however you
want to look at it is just the status
quo and which is funny because that
means they're actually conservatives in
a certain respect doesn't it um in the
most banal way
and that this is just the way that
reasonable you know people think about
it and that's a that's a clear case of
bias
so
not everything is going to fit on an
ideological spectrum of course as a
matter of fact we should probably think
of ideological dimensions
um but there will be a lot of cases like
that where you sort of red flags go go
up or alarm bells go off as you're
reading something you're like man this
this person really has an axe to grind
and not only does he have an axe to
grind sounds like he's from a group that
really has an axe to grind that should
probably make you not necessarily reject
that information source altogether
because sometimes they will come up with
something that the other people aren't
willing to look at
but to
to bracket it to a certain extent to say
i'm not sure what i'm going to get from
this but i'm not going to take this as
my my prime source
i think that it's very important at this
point in in our
society in in our development
to do what i call metaphorically
triangulation with respect to to news
by triangulation i don't mean just using
three sources
i mean using a variety of sources
which you
make a habit
of going to
from time to time to see what sort of
stories are are popping up
because you know it's it's interesting
if you're going to
a variety of different
sources it's not just how a particular
story is reported
where the bias comes in
it's whether a story is even worth
reporting on at all
or whether it's worth researching
um
you if you get yourself a wide range of
information sources and i'm not just
saying news organizations too i'll talk
about other
groups and
sites and things like that that you
might want to take a look at
but if you get yourself a variety
you can get a sense about what's what's
going on
in a much better way than if you're just
reading the new york times or the
washington post or
you know fox news or see it
msnbc or cbs or whatever
i would also suggest that it's important
to include a spectrum particularly for
an american
a spectrum of non-american news
and there are some major outlets that i
think are particularly
important to put into the mix bbc is one
of them
al jazeera is another
but i think it's also important for for
you to
look at the sites that are available
for french news sources for italian news
sources for brazilian news sources for
african news sources for chinese news
news sources that are available
in english or if you can actually read
the foreign languages i mean it's a
great way to practice it but it's also a
great way to to get information
i think that that's a very
useful thing to do and that takes some
time i'm not saying that you would have
to read every single one of these every
day or check out every story but
um it's a good thing to to make a
regular practice out of and i think one
way to sort of institutionalize this for
yourself
is if you're using firefox or chrome or
whatever i know that with firefox i've
got my my bookmarks bar across the top
and i have one particular
uh folder in there that's just labeled
news and opinion and it's got drop down
menus and some of you know there's other
folders under it some with major news
sources and what i include as major news
sources
is not just you know some of the big
papers or or outlets like that or
reuters where a lot of these stories are
coming from anyway or ap
but also china times or
china you know chinese financial uh
sites and and the india times and you
know you want to get
a good
spectrum
of representation in there and how is
that going to help you with with bias
because i'm supposed to be talking about
bias well you know when you see people
reporting things from different angles
it's not as if you're going to find one
that's totally without bias most likely
but you can play them off against each
other
and
you can you can almost by doing
something like a venn diagram see what
they actually have in common that they
agree on and then see where the
penumbras on the other side go off
and
you know where it might be coming from
their emphasis on this
and where it might be coming from their
emphasis on or interest in or or bias
against this
so those are those are important
strategies to pursue i think it's also
very important that you don't restrict
yourself to
news sources
a lot of news sources
a lot of websites economist is a great
example you know for for this
will not only have
straight out reporting
which often times you know is going to
require that the reporter
work a lot of contacts look at things
from a particular perspective which is
going to introduce some some degree of
bias right some things are going to be
emphasized other things not it's going
to rely on the reporters judgment
ultimately and putting together the
viewpoints that they're they're
analyzing and then and then synthesizing
into their article
but there's not only going to be
reporting
there's going to be opinion pieces
and i think that it's important to
sample a wide spectrum of opinion
across the board
and there you know that there's some
sort of bias going into it
not all biases are equal we're going to
get to that in in a little bit but you
want to hear what it is that intelligent
people
have to say
oftentimes very passionately
or at least argumentatively
about these topics
that's going to help you not only to
know what it is that these people you
know think that's going to help you to
weed through the bs
as time goes on
it's also going to help to reveal to you
what the sort of
networks of ideas or constellations of
concepts that constitute
various ideological perspectives
really look like so that
you become quicker and and more adept at
identifying oh that's coming from this
perspective oh that's coming from this
perspective this is looks like a blend
of these two perspectives
the more that you do that sort of thing
the more that you're actually parsing
good information like that
the closer you get to this approximation
where bias becomes less and less of a
problem
you're never going to eliminate bias
completely
i think it's a mistake to try to look
for
totally unbiased sources because there's
plenty of people who will peddle their
sources as being so i think that a lot
of the readers of the new york times
think that the new york times is totally
without bias
and i think that you know a lot of
people actually think that fox is fair
and balanced and both parties are
equally in the wrong about that
but there are a lot of people making
these sort of claims a lot of
organizations a lot of sources making
these claims and you don't want to buy
into them what you want to be able to do
is figure out what kind of bias it is
how bad the bias is is it really skewing
the analysis that the person is engaging
in
is it making them overlook things that
other news outlets are actually talking
about or people in opinion pieces are
saying hey you left out this bit of data
over here that's that's relevant to it
so that's that's that's very important
so there's this process of of
triangulation
not just triangulation but also looking
across various sources not just going to
news sources but also to opinion sources
the other thing that i would add to that
oftentimes at least in internet sources
when you have a story there's going to
be
things that are linked
follow up those links see where they go
to
if somebody is reporting a
story about
this thing that happened down in
tennessee odds are there's going to be a
local paper or local news source that
they're actually relying on
see what that story actually reads like
it might have less information it might
have more information but you won't know
until you actually dig
and go into it the great thing is with
the internet we're able to do that we
have this unparalleled power as
consumers that we didn't have before to
decide how we're going to follow out
these these stories it's really great
let's talk now about about bias itself
are all biases
equally bad i don't think so
i think that we could talk about
and i'm not going to like you know solve
this this problem here i just have some
suggestions but i think we can talk
about different modes of bias
i think that
for instance
when somebody is biased
in the sense of having a fixed position
from which they're working but they're
self-conscious about that position and
they've arrived at it through some sort
of process of inquiry
and they say look it's going to take an
awful lot to convince me to not be a
you know progressive
or not look at things in a neocon way or
not you know
analyze these things as a libertarian i
think we shouldn't
we shouldn't call that bias in the same
respect as some sort of knee-jerk
emotional unthinking unreflective
response that a lot of people have
so
and this is this applies very much to to
opinion pieces you know especially if
they're from these you know institutes
or think tanks that people have um
you know
they they don't get to to be in those
unless they've actually invested quite a
bit of time in acquiring information and
parsing it and thinking about how to
analyze it
so i don't think that we want to write
off all biases
as automatically being bad another thing
that we want to remember too is
bias can sometimes serve as a useful
filter that allows people to see things
that other people
can't get because of the noise
um now oftentimes what they're getting
are sort of artifacts of their
imagination
but sometimes it's actually true so
you know
you do want to be able to
entertain the possibility that a bias
source might be onto something
i think that it's very
good
to acquire some sort of understanding
about some of the main ideological
perspectives
that you're going to find within the
discourses that you're you're interested
in
and these are not all
political
or or social ones
um when you're analyzing questions of
religion religion reporting it tends to
be pretty bad across the board and i
would say that a lot of the biases in
religion reporting stem from
the ignorance on the part of reporters
about what it is that they're
they're discussing um and this this
extends through all sorts of cultural
products too you know here's a great
example
um roman catholics you know do they do
they go into a confessional to do a
confession
not very many of them and that hasn't
been the case for a couple generations
but you know movies and tv shows always
portray it like that because that's the
iconic representation and if you're a
reporter and you don't really know much
about this because you're on unchurched
and you you know you've lived a very
secular life you're going to assume that
that's the case because it's part of the
social imaginary that you're
participating in
likewise do we use the electric chair
when it comes to capital punishment or
do most states actually use lethal
injection
most went to lethal injection a long
time ago but that's not quite as
dramatic
and so people talk in in terms of the
these these things
so
you you want to
develop a knack
for telling
when somebody
doesn't know the whole story when they
didn't ask the right questions when they
made the wrong sort of blanket
assumptions
and that's going to come with time you
know i'm i'm
responding to a young person here who's
very well motivated to to learn and know
you don't by the way you don't have to
be a hundred percent infallible to to
detect bias in somebody else to suspect
there's bias going on there's nothing
that says that you yourself have to
become the premier information source in
order to criticize other information
sources
but it is it is good to know um
something about those that one is
attributing bias to
if you want to say that a source is
biased you should be able to articulate
to yourself what exactly in it is biased
if the best that you can come up with is
i don't know i just have a weird feeling
about it
that's probably not enough to say that
the source is biased you want to be able
to
determine what is it that that they're
leaving out what is it that clearly
they're not interested in pursuing
further
something else that i think that we want
to think about is
would we want to remove all bias
or
are there some upsides to bias i
mentioned before that you know the bias
will often be you know quite emotionally
invested in in something and and pursue
it in ways that other people won't
uh those who have other biases
um
i think that it's also nice to have a
a variety of perspectives you know
there's something about pluralism
that i think is quite good
um
you know people arrive at at the biases
that they have sometimes through
indoctrination
sometimes through
you know social processes of which
they're they're unaware
sometimes through
you know
having things merely imposed on them and
having to to parrot them but a lot of
times people arrive at at the the
perspectives that they have through
actually
carrying out some sort of process of
probably a flawed and imperfect process
but a process nonetheless
of dialogue inquiry analysis debate and
then they come to their best
viewpoint on it and and oftentimes you
know you'll you'll find that that people
quite a few people not everybody there
are some genuine ideologues out there
and there are some people who just have
you know personal problems that are
unwilling to to acknowledge that they're
they're
not as certain about things as they they
think they are but there's a lot of
people who are quite willing to
say well give me some other information
and i'll try to see if i can take this
in and make some sense out of it and and
revise my my picture
i think that's one of the things that
that
we want to be able to do as well is to
revise our our pictures of of these
these information sources we need to
keep learning
and revising
which ones we think are particularly
reliable sources and which ones we
we don't and probably for a younger
person even for some older people you
know if you're undergoing a process of
education
a life change that may
that may lead you to some sources and
away from other sources you may actually
say
yeah you know i used to really like the
economist i thought their analyses were
spot on but
i i don't know i feel that they've been
slipping lately or now i have a
different perspective
a broader perspective and i see that
thursday is a bit narrow in this respect
by the way this is a bad example because
the economist is is actually quite a
diverse news source there's some great
blogs uh with a variety of perspectives
um but you see where that's going
as you're you're learning more you're
going to incorporate more and more
news and information and opinion sources
into your manifold
by which you're sort of sifting out
current events
what i'd like to close with
is by thinking about social media
and giving a few pointers
and talking about a few of the
the issues and challenges
with respect to to that
so i think that um
when it comes to
news sources
it provided you not just sampling purely
partisan outlets
you can use twitter
you can use facebook with your likes you
can use linkedin
you can use google plus
as ways to access information i think
reddit could also be quite useful for
this but i can't talk much about reddit
because i don't really use it
there's a there's all sorts of other
sources as well that i think could be
quite quite useful youtube is is another
good good example
a lot of people used to get their news
through through email um
bursts they would you know set their
email to to get you know whenever there
was a news story published about this or
that
i don't know that many people who do
that these days in part because you tend
to get way too many emails
but
if you know a particularly good blog
and it's about something that you're
very interested in with politics or
culture or religion or
you know regional affairs or or
something like that or food who knows
what what you're interested in
uh it could be good to set set alerts of
that sort so that you get that
information but you know i know for
myself i
i have a variety of different
people that i follow on twitter and i've
got all these linkedin contacts and
you know i've got all these facebook
friends and then i have my facebook page
and my facebook page actually likes a
whole bunch of other pages
and through these these these uh
social media outlets i'm getting exposed
to a lot of different
stories
that i might otherwise miss out on
because you know i have friends who will
say i like this this blog or i'm going
to link this msnbc article
or i'm going to tweet this this uh
article that i think is important
and
now there's not enough time to actually
read everything of course so i'm i'm
pretty selective in that and i suspect
that one of the things actually
i said i was going to close with talking
about social media what i'm going to
close with is this
one of the things that the
the techno sphere
makes us conscious of when it comes to
news
is just how little news we're actually
able to take yet
because if you're doing the sort of
strategies that i was talking about you
know having a variety of different news
sources and trying to go to them you're
not going to read every story you're not
going to follow up every possibility
you only have the same 24 hours a day
that you know back in 1940 people had
and back in 240 a.d people had and that
in
you know whatever time we pick in the
future people are going to have that's a
constant you only got so much time
so the question is which stories are you
going to
to allow to inform you by you doing the
work of you know clicking on them and
running your eyeballs over them and
trying to keep your your brain active
and parsing them
is that a bad thing
this this awareness
it could induce a kind of depression i
can't really know anything
you know i can't possibly follow things
it could induce a kind of anxiety i'm
always uh you know
i'm always out of the know when it comes
to important news items
i think it'd be better if it just
induces a kind of humility there's a lot
of things that we just don't know about
if we want to know
a lot more about this one that means
that all this other stuff has got to
wait or or not happen
and the news cycle constantly
keeps going on
i think that the more that you
that you consume news in a
self-conscious
way to try to avoid bias to try to use
different sources
the faster that you get at
telling what's what's worth reading from
what's not reading worth reading
and the the better you get about putting
together this entire constellation of
ideas that you use to locate things
but
even then you know you're you're still
only taking in a a portion of what's
available and i think that's okay
that's part of the human condition
um
and
so that's that's where i'll leave off
that's pointing us towards an important
facet of human experience in this this
world that we now call the techno sphere